right oh how about the fights this
weekend mma in boxing
do you see uh alexander yeah oh my god
brunner looks
what would you think when that fight you
think so i didn't think you won that
fight i gotta agree with you
he started too late but i saw glimpses
of old ab but i know but let me let me
just look better than he's looking a
long time but he's still not like he's
not talking one judge had it 117 111 was
crazy he went to sleep like i bet on the
derrick lewis fight
because he's a four to one dog and then
my girl's like are you gonna bet on
adrien broner because we're switching
that i'm like
i do not bet unlocked yeah it's too
corrupt yeah like you can't
it's gonna go to the judges yeah yeah
they already have the favorite all right
because if you're gonna make money you
want to bet on the dogs hell no no he'll
win that fight he got it
he started too santiago went to the body
like did work
that post interview clip you sent us
cracked me up did you send it to us
yeah yeah yeah yeah he what did he say
he said uh
they said what are you gonna do he said
well i forget what he said he goes i was
like thirteen dollars
thirteen dollars thirteen dollars that
thirteen million
yeah i forget what he said having sex
having something like that but i was
like damn brother you just got back so
this went to decision
yeah he could have stopped i don't think
you won that fight man
either way they're setting them up for
failure because that fight doesn't say
oh he's ready for the top ten
top five they're gonna give him some dog
decks dog yeah oh they
are that's not gonna end well and he's
supposed to fight at once
who does he fight then did he say who he
want
no i didn't say anyone but again i'm
pretty sure you called somebody out i
thought
oh i didn't get to that i just saw the
chicken that's his first one in four
years yeah
i don't know abs tough man i think
there's a lot of uh
mental health [ __ ] there i think it's
the good fight for him and again we were
talking about this
jay and i um what's danny garcia
that's a comeback they're coming back
come back fight for i don't think he
beats danny
i don't think he's acting enough to beat
anybody yeah yeah he needs like two more
one more thing everybody's telling
showtime he's like man
fight let me fight he's like so i stay
out of trouble he's like vomiting here i
can't get in trouble out there so keep
me fighting
oh damn how old is he 31 31
two he's up he's up there
and then uh yeah the interviewer was
like
you know on twitter they think you lost
that fight he's like twitter hates me
who gives a [ __ ]
that is that's no that's true now he has
a point that's just where bias is
oh my god they hate him they can't
accept him except for uh abner morris
he was the only one he was like give him
give him a chance he's like that jab was
good he's throwing good combos
but then even abner was real at the end
he was like i don't think he won that
fight
let's get a little clips from body shot
head shot look at that look at everybody
uh poor san diego you never see him
again never like
never that was his one chance he did he
did good now i think i could throw him a
bone he'd be probably be a journeyman
for someone else like a champion what
does that mean journeyman
like uh basically he's going to be like
to step up like they say a prospect is
going to like want to go to the next
level
he's going to be that guy that's that
that's the guy you got to get yeah you
got to fight i think he might have
he has like an upset in him got good you
know technical skills with him
13 look yeah yeah broner scammer said
he said rest weekend we're going to be
flipping bottles and have sex i'll be
back in the gym after this weekend
it's a long weekend i like it
bro he didn't lose he'll be the biggest
boxer ever yeah
oh my god he's [ __ ] hilarious yeah
he's so funny
he's so funny and it's good he's not
active enough or not yeah like in the
ring he's just you know
throw ten punches in a round why why
would he be shot he's shocked though
ever since that marco's madonna knocked
out you know that takes you home nah oh
really taking years off your life
was that before the pacquiao fight yeah
way before wave oh got it i think
there's a lot of mental health issues
because when i remember when he lost
that pacquiao fight he was like
he thought he won but it was clear that
was funny that's
that's a b just trolling oh he's oh he
was just trying to say he lost to mikey
garcia
and he took a lot of licks that fight
didn't throw any punches like after that
mark
marcos beat him up michael beat the piss
out yeah so it's just like he you know
years ago he getting hit in the head
like yeah cranium got a little
concussion there buddy did you see the
knockout on espn did i see it oh my god
yeah bro alex i knew oscar bell dad i
still think
uh curse blade's knockout was worse then
then oscars curtis was flatline facebook
that is knockout
but no oscar on his back foot throwing
uh
a hook was beautiful and this boy was he
was
he's [ __ ] off you can hear that he's
that he's the underdog by the way oscar
boom he's throwing him up he's [ __ ]
up the whole fight yeah
and then finally just put him away but
he like battered this poor dude yeah
and he was the underdog where's that one
though it's kind of you'll see he's
coming
yeah it was [ __ ] he got [ __ ] up he had
to go to the hospital didn't he
oh yeah i know i know you talk about
this one below the belt oh
god damn goddamn yeah damn
that's the one bat on the back plant
boom boom
dip dip check hook night night yep see
it
see it right here you already in
position meet me oh
that was beautiful [ __ ] that was
beautiful he was asleep
he was asleep um we had a discussion i
know uh who's we
uh okay a couple of boxers though okay
performer
um the new age of boxing is different
because you see a lot of
punches you didn't see in the past it's
getting like like lead uppercuts
no one ever threw lee uppercuts back in
like the 90s or the
2000s like nah but tyson would but they
gave me balls
the game involves now but it's like new
like they're throwing a lot of up
because it's jabs now
so it's like if you're uni like i sport
the other day with this guy
and it's like this new generation i
can't i'm like oh [ __ ] i gotta get out
i'm gonna comment
they're throwing uppercuts now like lead
up because instead of jabs they're
throwing hooks
i'm like god damn like i'm talking about
check cause double three three hooks
yeah so this new generator like a jab
yeah so i'm saying
it's going to be a lot more knockouts
now because you when you first start
they train
for the conditioner what tactical
fighter like one two one two one two
threes one two uppercuts
now it's like yo you don't know what to
see everything is wild that's crazy
i don't know why you're spying uh i
wonder if there is more knockouts
yeah there's more knockoffs now i don't
i don't know is there a chin how can we
give you the
stats of not you're talking about like
typing year-to-year stats of
uh knockouts in boxing
like big fights though ufc's had two
walk-off knockouts back to back and
they're
bad man walk the walk uh back to back oh
back to back
i thought he said walk the walk
fifty percent of box match about thirty
percent that's not that's not saying
much
let's take a look at this
boxes when was this jen i don't know
oh never mind 2013. no that's not going
to work
what did you google your statistics of
knockouts in boxing
yeah i don't know if it's higher you
don't think oh
well just look at all the pay-per-view
fights the big fights in boxing
like uh the tank knockout this was a
knockout i'm not talking about bruno
because he's coming off of what two-year
layoff three-year layoff
uh the earl spence and danny garcia
danny garcia has a chin on him but he
could have stopped him
but he didn't he didn't you right uh you
don't live and could have okay don't let
me cut them
knockouts um tyson fury knocked out uh
and he also he was throwing like look
what he was doing though throwing wild
punches and
you know wilder as well so he got wild
with him uh anthony joshua
i mean it's just so many people uh oh
derek derek just got knocked out by um
uh alex povecki and another uh lead
uppercut
knocked him out slept yeah i wonder if
it is uh
so we had a discussion like yo this
boxing generation the the fact that you
don't see like these punches like
throwing
like like as the lead elite uppercut is
a jab yeah but they adapt to it just
like everybody
adapt to the other stuff because there's
only so much you can do in boxing you
only have two arms
that's true and that's it yeah but they
train mentally train you like the one
two and stationary punches but now i'm
just saying it's gonna be more knockouts
i hope you're right boxing needs it yeah
it needs the knockouts
it's a great weekend for fights period
so why are you still sparring
yeah why are you sparring keep my stuff
tight i know but what you don't make
money
you don't you don't make money doing
that yeah but you know wild card boxing
you know sometimes
you go in there train hit the bag a
little bit and you see the new guys
coming up like yeah
you know glove up so i glove up and uh
yeah i get out
did you spar when you quit ufc never
dude my brain's mine you were like done
yeah hell no oh yeah girl don't matter
they say hey you're actually worse ct
what you mean the headgear increases it
because you you can take more shots
over with the hit with the padding let's
say if you don't have headgear on let's
say
we're sparring mma the only way to do
this but if i had four ounce gloves on i
hit you
and you drop and we stopped sparring
then you got the one hit
but if we're boxing a headgear on and i
hit you with that same punch and you can
take it
but you're not as wobbly you hit again
you get more concussion and again more
oh yeah
hit again because the pattern and then
the realizing just the jab is [ __ ]
guys that was ct
like even though what little ones are
like like this yeah straight forward
that's straight up i'm glad i didn't
fight
that's a tough girl yeah i'm glad i
didn't do that oh my bad cheerleading
was tight
you're making suffer to see so box
cameras as well perhaps take your crits
false sense of safety
boxers take more risk also makes the box
head bigger target
the scene thing's a big deal i hate
wearing stupid headgear yeah yeah the
cnn oh you were getting a ring jim
no just before just just messing around
but i can't see that well so i'd rather
have no
nothing at all so i can see every little
thing on the sides
your ass that's what they do dog i'm
over here hey man i'll kick your ass
like that that's what they do and he got
the nose guard as well you got a nose
guard yeah rock
kick your ass hell yeah yeah looking at
you like this
but that's weird i didn't know that uh
concussions that's why boxing's more
dangerous than
mma yeah because if you get wobbly in
mma
you're stopped finish and they stop it
boxing you get an eight count
stand back up you already have brain
damage then you get more brain damage
and spawn you got to get up that's like
hold on i still need my work i've seen
so many people get knocked down and like
hold on wait done
damn it are you serious especially if
they pan them too man [ __ ] that
employee and what's that [ __ ] y'all
talking about the dog house yeah the dog
that's what i'm talking about
yeah the doghouse they bark it they bark
at you and [ __ ] or whatever
i saw somebody some dude in the dog
house get knocked down
and he was like hold on man nah nah
let's do it run it back and he literally
the first two punch boom boom got set on
and he was like nah that's enough he's
like hold on just give him some water
he'll be all right
are you serious yeah nope
nope cheerleading was fine oh okay so
yeah so snowboarding i used to go down
there with my family a big bear
and uh now we should rent a cabin and
they tell you to like you just
just like you know to break you got to
put like both feet in between but i was
twisting too well do you feed him
because i mean
yeah because in the middle that's how
you break that's how you you break in
the middle to slow down
what do you put your feet well you have
the board fate like to slow down you'd
have the board
face like just sort of you got to yeah
just like horizontal
horizontal yeah horizontal yes then you
push your heels in to back yeah you
did you not break once when you're out
there yeah i did but you said something
about feet in between
no your feet parallel and you your heels
back and that's how you break
yeah okay you just you're just saying it
differently yeah probably they said
cross
sit cross your feet cross your feet
close your eyes so you know when you
stop you gotta cry
well i mean i mean i swear to god we
gotta get you some [ __ ] books
we gotta get a book i didn't say cross
between i said like y'all i said cross
my head just say cross
i say you want your hips because you
know front and back from la school
districts man they [ __ ] up they're
tough out here man
bro all right jim what do you guys got
how about that
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this from a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son